Lucifer was one of these angels He was a
dreamer with Fantastical ideas for all
of creation but he was seen as a
troublemaker by the Elders of Heaven for
they felt his way of thinking was
dangerous to the order of their world so
he watched as the Angels began to expand
the universe in their ways from the dust
of Earth they created Adam and Lilith
equals as the first of mankind but
despite
this so a lot of people are going to
wonder what l who's Lilith I know Adam
and Eve Who's Lilith Lilith is a figure
from Jewish folklore and so it Lilith is
not a figure from scripture Lilith is
not a figure from church tradition but
Lilith appears in the Babylonian talmud
and some other Jewish folklore and she's
presented as the first wife of Adam who
refused to submit to Adam so already
you're seeing a fairly I mean you've
seen it from the beginning of a fairly
novel take on the uh creation story